this is an unbelievable story you know
the Wright loves to talk about uh ballot
drop boxes they're bad they're not
secure they're unreliable and yet the
reason that they are not as trusted by
some Americans is because Republicans
are saying you can't trust them it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy it's a vicious
circle it's endless and now
individuals believe to be right-wingers
have been spotted in some cases armed at
Arizona ballot drop boxes Arizona
Secretary of State Katie Hobbs received
the report this week about an alleged
incident of voter intimidation video was
obtained by The Washington Post and
we're going to play the video here for
you and I will describe what is visible
there is a man who parks at one of these
ballot drop boxes and he walks over and
he dumps in his ballot perfectly legal
that's what it's there for this was on
October 17th this is an early voting
Dropbox and what you see is that after
he walks away
something gets his attention right
across the street he's apparently
engaging with someone right across the
street and it seems to start to become
sort of uh combative and the man later
reported that he was being watched he
was being photographed and he was being
heckled as he used that ballot Dropbox
and again if you're listening I'm
describing what's on video the
individual eventually getting into his
car uh backing up and ultimately driving
away but what he says happened was that
people were harassing him for using that
Dropbox and he ultimately decided to
seems like back all the way out
um and go in a different direction that
is exhibit number one we then learned
about on Friday two armed individuals
dressed in tactical gear showed up at a
Mesa Arizona ballot drop box we have
pictures here
um eventually the Maricopa County
Sheriff's Office arrived and the
individuals left uh there are folks here
you see wearing I don't even know the
terms for this stuff they've got like a
uh I can't tell if that is a leg a leg
holster of some kind with one individual
they seem to have a tactical vest
possibly a camera uh who knows what it
is that that they all have but
reportedly armed individuals in tactical
gear again allegedly uh there to
apparently there
um to uh harass and intimidate and all
of the things that you would imagine uh
they would be doing and then there is an
additional report of people just hanging
out outside Maricopa County elections
headquarters in Arizona outside one of
two ballot drop boxes they have their
own cameras rolling they are filming the
dropboxes and uh here are people and
they they're all playing koi I can't
really tell you what I'm doing here
check this out
so what we're seeing right now is just a
bunch of cameras pointing at the
dropboxes
what was the name of the group you're
with again
clean elections USA
clean elections USA
and you've been out here how
are you I can't answer that
they claim that they have not said
anything to people dropping off ballots
they just have cameras pointed at the
dropboxes they have you know a dog a
bunch of cameras food
etc etc now individually
is it against the law to just have a
camera across you know the parking lot
from a Dropbox I don't know I don't know
and that's what's being explored right
now but the totality of what's going on
in Arizona and I don't care who's doing
it if you came to me with tears in your
eyes and said sir these are all
Democrats I would say it's still wrong
okay I don't care who's doing it this is
all a form of voter intimidation and
there's also a story here of what
appears to be essentially inaction by
law enforcement
um which is another part of this that
we're exploring and may have more
information about uh about uh for you
tomorrow they are you know it's uh the
other day Michael Marco Rubio said
listen
people don't trust these ballot drop
boxes right but they don't trust them
because you told them they shouldn't be
trusted it's completely circular in
every way and now in order to set to be
able to justify their own claims that
these drop boxes are just trouble
they are creating trouble at the drop
boxes these are horrible people this is
not pro-democracy Behavior by any means
and we have to see to it that it is
stopped in Arizona
everything you do online can be tracked
by your ISP by Tech platforms the
government hackers everyone should be
using a VPN every time you connect to
the internet you turn it on once you
forget about it it's easy many vpns
secretly record your browsing and
download history but our sponsor private
internet access is the only VPN with the
bulletproof commitment to never doing
that because they're the only VPN that
has proven their no log policy multiple
times in court their systems are also
independently audited by Deloitte to
verify no logging private internet
access has a Next Generation server
infrastructure with IP addresses in 83
countries and all 50 U.S states it's one
of the only vpns fast enough for
streaming video and downloading large
files for instance private internet
access lets me access a bunch of great
international soccer I can't otherwise
get VP ends can be very helpful with the
upcoming World Cup and private internet
access has a 30-day money-back guarantee
24 7 customer support and my audience
gets 82 percent off that's just two
dollars and 11 cents a month plus three
months free go to
piavpn.com David the link is in the
podcast notes